make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so Batman fans are probably gonna
hate me after this video because I think
that what we're gonna do here is make a
pretty compelling case of why Batman is
a terrible superhero so with the city of
Bane of course we picked up in the first
video that basically what we saw was
like the fall of Batman right the fall
of Bruce Wayne and in his place
Thomas Wayne essentially took over as
Batman in Gotham City now those guys who
were who were playing catch up here um I
invite you guys to watch the videos down
in the description they'll get you
totally caught up on on everything
that's going on but the idea and really
kind of the big question people had to
ask was if Gotham City had been taken
over by Bank and if all those various
villains who sided with Bane became the
new law enforcement arm of Bane's Bane
city and then those villains who chose
not to or those heroes who were there
were either captured and turned or else
you know imprisoned or what have you
then how is the rest of the country
interpreting that how does the rest of
the country deal with it how does
metropolis deal with that where
Superman's out how did they view that
and this is a cool thing because what is
up happening here is we're basically met
by the arrival of Captain Atom now for
those of you guys who were playing catch
up here when it comes to Captain Atom
there have been a couple different
iterations of his character there's the
original that appeared back in space
adventures I think it was back in 1960
that was created by Charlton comics
those guys who don't know Charlton
comics was a comic book publisher
alongside Marvel and DC at the tunnel
really even before Marvel he was largely
DC and then Charlton and a couple other
comic book publishers were releasing
stories again all this really kind of
came out of Barry Allen the idea that
Barry Allen was the first attempt to
blend science fiction with superhero
themes and like create an origin story
that was rooted in both but because the
success of Barry Allen because of the
success of the flash he basically got a
whole bunch of science-based heroes and
that was the nature of Allen Adham back
in the day now after the events of
crisis on Infinite Earths going into
like 1987 DC came back and introduced
like a new version of his character
named Nathaniel Adam but the overall
gist of this is that Captain Atom is a
guy who can like manipulate pretty much
an infinite amount of energy and then
channel that energy in a variety of ways
but the overall point here is that when
it comes to his character captain Adams
a heavy hitter and for the most part
he's like a government guy the idea
behind this is that if captain Adams
shows up then usually it seems to
indicate that like things are gonna pop
off or something's going to take place
designed to sort of elevate a character
right because this is a guy they can go
toe-to-toe with Superman and depending
on what stories you're reading can
actually
overpower Superman so it really kind of
it really sort of depends on their but
this basically picks up with Gotham girl
now the cool thing about this is that
with this event unfolding with Gotham
girl it is kind of an interesting
question what would happen if Gotham
girl face off against someone who is as
immensely powerful as Captain Atom and
the answer to this is that she
absolutely beats the tar out she
absolutely thrashes him and that's kind
of the funny thing because remember when
it comes to to Gotham girl her powers
are basically sort of ambiguous right
it's one of these things that was never
really cleared up it's just the idea
that she you know basically traded a
portion of her life force or at least
allows her life force to be drained
based on how much power she uses right
so like absolute power quote unquote
like whatever that power happens to be
now by and large it seems to follow the
form and function of your standard
run-of-the-mill abilities right so like
flights SuperSpeed durability different
things like that but the result is that
the more she uses her powers the more
she strains them the more of her life
she loses and so facing off against
someone like Captain Atom is not a small
thing that's a pretty significant chunk
of energy for her to use because he's
such a heavy hitter but she absolutely
like trashes him she rips him to pieces
and now it's also kind of interesting
about this is that Tom King tries to
sort of build this scenario where Gotham
is essentially in the midst of a civil
war the heroes and the villains versus
those villains who have been turned to
the side of Bane or joined the side of
being willingly and in all reality
here's one of the issues that you run
into right like when it when it comes to
trying to build a kind of civil war like
a story that basically says like
everything sort of blowing up it's kind
of hard to do that when the stakes don't
really seem that high which is to say
the characters who could die don't
really seem that important in the first
place right like when it comes to the
character of Gotham girl she's largely
been a background character really up
until this point she played a big role
in the first arc and now she's playing a
role in this arc but there's no real
there's there's nothing that really kind
of ties you in and really kind of brings
you to sort of feel for her character or
want to be a part of that whole
landscape that she's with when you
switch over to a scenario where you've
got tight man you've got Tweedledee
Tweedledum and then you've got you got
scarecrow you're essentially talking
about villains that aside from scarecrow
aren't really all that interesting in
the first place it's so like when one of
the tweedle brother one of the yeah one
of the tweto brothers gets shot and then
you end up having the father of Bruce
Wayne who essentially was the one who
pulled the trigger right like Thomas
Wayne for the flash point universe who's
the one that pulled the trigger and shot
him this is just kind of like okay I
mean I guess it's interesting because
usually when it comes to trying to
create a situation where you're sort of
showing stakes that it's like if we lose
everything Falls it kind of requires a
whole bunch of hairs that people care
about right like look at Marvel Civil
War for example you look at Marvel Civil
War and it was the entirety of the
superhero community but what made it so
impactful is that it was everyone from
the very very top heroes like Iron Man
and and Captain America and so on all
the way down to the lower level heroes
like Tigre who basically quit because
she's a college kid she's like I don't
have time to get involved in this whole
Civil War and go to college I don't have
time for that you know it was it was all
the small little nooks and crannies and
were to really do something like this
what you would need is a big event
otherwise you just kind of seems like
things are happening in Gotham and it's
business as usual when in reality this
story's not the story is about Bane
taking over the entirety of Gotham City
which is a huge thing but the result is
of the way it's written it kind of seems
to sort of fly by and then not a whole
lot of notice gets it and that's
basically it and the story's done and we
move on to the next gap so it's kind of
like kind of takes away you know it
takes away for a little bit and it kind
of sucks but you have this really cool
moment where you end up having like
Catwoman right now Catwoman being around
it Catwoman being part of the the Batman
story for the most part was was kind of
like remember she's a victim here right
the idea was that she actually wanted to
marry Bruce Wayne but through Bane's
mecha nations he essentially used a
friend of Selina Kyle to trick Selina
into believing that the only way Bruce
Wayne could be happy as if he was Batman
that if she were to marry him and she
were to ask him to walk away and they
went and pursued whatever goals it is
they wanted to pursue to her Europe for
the rest of their lives the result was
that she'd actually be taken away from
happiness and so she walked away from
but in learning the truth about the
situation and learning what's really
going on here we end up finding out
she's the one who rescued Bruce Wayne
that when Bruce was left at the bottom
of this cavern the Oh bye-bye Thomas
Wayne she's the one that picked him up
she's the one that found him she's the
one that brought him here you know we
saw that in the last video and now you
have it kind of playing out where he's
just recovering in her house and it's
kind of a cool little moment here but
again it just doesn't really seem
impactful it doesn't really just seem
like man I'm so glad this is going on so
it's kind of like cool you know and then
you just kind of go on and it's
interesting I don't really mean to do
that's a tear Tom King down what I mean
to say here is that this may be one of
these things that the entire run of Tom
Kane may be one of those things where it
kind of reads better in trade but when
you go like story by story you go issue
by issue it doesn't feel so cohesive
maybe it's just this one particular
chronic goods for the most part I had
loved his run up until this point so
there's just this one particular thing
but what he does here is he actually for
it's pretty cool emphasis on the
character of kite man
now kite man was for the most part like
not even a Z less villain like
whatever's lower than Z writes like an a
a villain if you're following the Excel
spreadsheet formula
he's like a below XIV Ilyn this is a guy
that's like almost totally and
completely irrelevant and doesn't really
have anything to do with anybody but the
cool thing about kite man is like he
flies around he's just like tight man
hell yeah like it's cool like it's one
of the one of the coolest little things
he originally appeared back in the the
war of jokes and riddles I'm pretty sure
but basically like it's kind of a ragtag
thing now this I think does an
exceedingly good job of showing us how
dire things are right like under normal
circumstances you would never see
scarecrow spending time and socializing
with someone like kite man I mean that's
just it would even for scarecrow he'd be
like yeah I mean you're cool man but
like you don't really belong at the cool
kids table like go sit with the other
guys over there you know like the cool
kids are hanging out and we're all gonna
skip class we're all gonna go to like
makeout point
I don't I don't know I don't know what
kids do these days but what it does is
it sets things up really really well
right because Gotham is really kind of
walking a knife's edge and and when that
happens when that unfolds what you're
doing here is you're you're giving us a
scenario where you're essentially saying
like everybody's really just kind of
banding together as best they can like
at this point there is no
differentiation when it comes to like
classes of villains you know it's
basically those who and those
individuals who have been like taken
over to Bane's side and those who don't
want to those who are trying to kind of
keep Gotham a relatively safe place and
so it's interesting because then you
switch over and you suddenly start
getting these members of the bad family
who are having these conversations with
each other right I mean they're kind of
having these these talks you have Damian
Wayne who's talking to Tim Drake and
it's cool the way this happens because
what you get here is a sort of
explanation on whether or not things are
right and this is where I say I think a
lot of Batman fans may have disagreeing
with me here because when I look at the
city of Gotham you look at the Batman
comics and you look at the city of
Gotham and it's like Batman's a crappy
hero because if that was a good hero
Gotham wouldn't be bad
there would be a measure to change with
Gotham improving but that's never
happened in fact because of Batman now
you've got like the Joker who was really
Batman's own creation you've got to face
you've got the penguin you've got like
like a scarecrow you got Killer Croc you
have all these these characters of these
super villains who didn't exist before
Batman so what about and they've done
what Bruce had done is his parents got
shot you know as mommy and daddy got
shot he got upset he wouldn't travel the
world to make sure that nobody had to
deal with that again and he said the
best way to do is to come back to Gotham
and make things worse and
basically what happened and it's kind of
a cool situation here because this whole
debate that goes on between Damian Wayne
and and Tim Drake is this question of
are things really bad though
I mean sure like like people are being
stripped of their free will all I kind
of get stuff and they're being made to
serve on behalf of Dane but the city's
better what's the alternative
given their free will back and watch the
whole city fall apart again I mean
that's kind of the cool thing that's
that's kind of this cool debate is well
I love these debates so much it's
because your people will kind of say
well if they should definitely have
their free will I mean I guess if you
just want to watch the city fall apart
but if they had if the people of Gotham
City had the ability to make their city
a better place they would have either
they've chosen not to or they've been
incapable of doing it but regardless of
the circumstance they failed on all
levels and so because of that like
somebody else has to come in and force
their hand and say if you're not gonna
do it then I'll do it myself and that's
what Bane did that's such a remainded he
came and took over the city and like
it's kind of a cool theme because like
there's no real crime anymore the only
people you have to worry about the only
people that are being tracked down by
the forces of vane are the villains who
haven't sided with them or haven't been
caught and turned over to them yet right
but you look at a scenario like this and
people say well individuals you know
they deserve their free will what
they're really saying is this city
deserves to rot the city deserves to
fall apart because that's what's going
to happen because that's what always has
happened and that's because no one's
taken any steps to keep that from
happening
I mean even Batman made it worse right
like that I mean you gotta have a hero
here a vigilante or hero or into your
whatever you want to call it who says
look at these guys who were incorrigible
and there's really no reason for them to
stop doing what they're doing but gosh
golly I just believed that if I arrest
them enough times they'll stop you know
I can fix them I can rehabilitate them
no he can't Batman's a failure as a
superhero because Batman's not willing
to do what needs to be done in order to
make sure that the villains are stopped
and that's why Bane worked because he is
the guy who wins the war is the guy
who's willing to do what the other
person isn't even if it means selling
your humanity even it means giving up
your humanity either that or it's an
endless war that will go on forever and
that's really that that's really kind of
the way the Gotham is it's an endless
conflict that goes on forever and ever
and ever because Batman's inept and a
failure as a superhero and that's why I
say I think Batman fans will hate me
because of that but it doesn't mean I'm
wrong and that's kind of the funny thing
about this is because it's just sort of
this kind of discussion right the bat
family cannot go into Gotham City if
they do that Bane will kill Alfred and
so because of the fact that they're not
willing to sacrifice the life of Alfred
then they're saying well then we'll just
kind of like
keep doing as they're going right I mean
at the end of the day you gotta choose a
side
everybody's got to draw straws
somebody's gonna get the short one and
this instance is Alfred I mean the guy's
old he's almost done with almost living
anyway so why does it really matter but
if I'm a member of the bat family I'm
saying hey look
Alfred's one man there's a city with
millions of people that need to be saved
or whatever it is it needs to happen or
something that like we need to act sorry
about your luck Alfred it's been real
and it's been good you just got to cut
him loose and that's and that's just the
way it goes it's harsh but people with
soft spots don't win wars and so it's
kind of cool you know when it when it
comes to this conflict here because what
you end up having is is sort of Thomas
Wayne talking to Gotham girl and asking
her tell me what you hear like like what
are you here in the city of Gotham she's
like I don't hear any for anybody
calling the police
I don't hear anybody calling for help I
don't hear anybody getting mugged I
don't hear any of those things I hear a
quiet city I hear a peaceful city I hear
a city that's better than it's ever been
under the rule of Bruce Wayne and that's
why it's awesome is because at the end
of the day Bane succeeded Bane did what
he wanted to do Bane made Gotham a
better place so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to commerce
explain and make sure you guys to the
saw button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later
Bruce
[Music]